good morning believe nation today's
message is unchain your mind over to you
Ct Fletcher
your mind untain your mind from the
imprisonment of fear unchain your mind
it's been encaged with doubt unchain
your mind lose yourself let yourself
free from the binds of average for the
rise of normal lose yourself from
intimidation let yourself free let your
mind go shift your focus your focus your
intensity your tribe your everything
should be put into the amount the amount
of efforts that you are going to put
into that attempt you cannot fail you
cannot fail if you give 100% of your
effort mother you cannot feel it is
impossible there was a lady I don't
remember the lady's name but I remember
her act she came in absolutely last in
America everybody had crossed the finish
line she was the last person in the
stadium then lights was getting dark and
she fell down 25 yards before the finish
line but that lady is crawled she
crawled people tried to rush out and
help her the medics came out tiny but
she sued him away she sued away and she
drugged her himself across that finish
line
that it's a kind of attitude that I want
you to have that's what you focus on you
focus on giving that mother everything
you've got within you so anything can
change your mind remember when when like
you told me that I should do like
cooking video at the very beginning I
said no no I can't do and can't do it
and you kept pushing me to do it yeah I
was really scared at first like first
few times and when I did it I forgot
what I want to say even under and I
still don't remember what I want to say
perhaps I wasn't as scared as I used to
be and I won't be like oh no I can't do
it I can't do it like you know but
because of you you pushed me to do this
and I am okay with it like I could do it
I wasn't as scared as I used to be I
don't know if I want to do more of the
cooking videos cool I think the
important message for me is from this is
the biggest enemy that you have isn't
your friends or your family or you know
the people around you it's you like it's
what's in your head it's it's here right
like that's the biggest thing that holds
you back it's it's the reasons why you
tell yourself that you can't be where
you are and you know look at any major
goal that you have look at the goal you
know it's New Year look at the goal that
you set for yourself last year and you
didn't accomplish you there's some big
goal for yourself
and ask yourself well why haven't I done
that right why haven't I made that
five-year goal happen yet and you're
gonna come up with reasons right and all
logical valid rational reasons that
anybody would understand but really
those are just stories that you're
telling yourself right like it's it's
getting past that block in your head to
feel like you can only be this kind of
person and that all those logical
reasons actually exist in our blocks
once you get through that and we all
have it like I'm not trying to preach
and say I'm perfect I still have a - the
reason why I'm not bigger than I am now
I could come up with reasons and if I
look at them really they're just stories
and every major breakthrough that I've
had in my life
has been from breaking through unlimited
personal belief and and that's helped me
shoot to the next up and things that
still hold me back or other now bigger
limiting beliefs but there's still
limiting personal beliefs and so the
biggest battle that you have to face is
what's in your head you're fighting with
yourself and I think the way out of it
is to surround yourself with with people
with ideas with resources that help you
think bigger that help you shake out of
the habits of mediocrity it's why I
started the and special series to have
big ideas to start my day with every day
losing that losing the Sun it's okay I'm
going with ongoing anyway Stein is here
doesn't matter
that's a limiting excuse right I can't
shoot video because it's dark no I'm
gonna keep on shooting video right
alright just surround yourself with
resources ideas things that make you
come alive things that make you think
bigger things that make you believe in
yourself and if you consistently do that
then slowly you'll be able to unbreak
those chains that are holding you and
your mind back so question the date
today is what's holding you back what's
holding you back I like it we're going
deep going deep so what's holding you
back leaving the comments below and will
join the discussion Sun is gonna come
back in three in two in one and then
come back it's coming back I promise
it's coming back it's coming back there
it is thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another before that was amazing
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you soon